[inaudible].
Thank you,
Jack.
A A force of nature.
You're so a pleasure to be here.
Uh,
I want to just actually tee up a bunch of quick conversations that we can carry
to our fireside chat and conversation with you.
Uh,
so first of all,
I'm clear that were alive during the most extraordinary time ever in human
history,
right?
There's never been a better time to be alive other than perhaps tomorrow.
Uh,
we're at a time where each of us have more power than nation.
States had a,
at heads of industries had just decades or a century ago.
We forget how amazing the world is,
right?
We forget that a hundred years ago in 2019 and 1918 in that one year alone,
50 million people died from the Spanish flu,
right?
20 odd million people died from World War One scale that to today's population,
you'd be talking about a quarter of a billion people that would have passed away
this year.
So we forget,
despite all of the negative news on what I call the crisis news network and so
forth,
we're still living in an amazing time.
Uh,
it's also true that I think none of us really understand how fast the world is
changing.
Uh,
we're living in a world where technologies across the board are growing
exponentially.
You know,
computation,
sensors,
networks,
AI,
robotics,
three d printing,
synthetic biology,
ar,
VR,
blockchain.
All of those technologies are themselves accelerating,
but it's the combination of two,
three,
or four of those together that are accelerating things add to that,
the notion that in the next six years,
we're going from 3.8 billion people connected on planet earth last year,
at the end of 2017 to 8 billion people connected,
right?
We're adding 4 billion new minds into the global conversation,
have never been there before.
And that's a massive empowerment for acceleration.
Add to that,
in fact,
that we've got more capital available flowing than ever before.
We hit all time highs in venture fund,
seed funding,
crowd funding.
Um,
I see shows a sovereign investment,
so more capital flowing at the same time that all the technology that we're
using to make stuff happening is demonetizing faster than ever before.
Right?
The human genome was sequenced for $100 million in 2001 today it's circa 500
bucks.
Alumina is projecting a $100 in one hour as is the Beijing Genome Institute.
So there's more money.
Everything we need to do is cheaper,
right?
And look at Google cloud computation capabilities.
And so more people,
more money,
cheaper stuff,
more experimentation.
And what it means is we're entering a period of a hyper acceleration,
right?
As I think about how fast the world is going,
it's not slowing down.
And in fact,
you know,
it's an acceleration,
the acceleration that we're hitting.
So that makes for an amazing,
amazing future.
And one of the things that I focus on a lot is the notion that there is no
problem we cannot solve.
All right?
And I'm clear that the right combination of technology,
talent,
and treasure are,
can take on any problem.
And,
and my message to a lot of people around the world is you're now empowered.
If you are sick and tired about a problem or you're inspired to solve something,
you can,
uh,
it's a matter of do yours.
Do you give yourself permission to be that audacious and go do it?
A hundred years ago,
the only people could actually solve a problem at any scale.
We're the nation states,
right?
Or were the robber barons,
the industrialists and even all they could do was unleash monetary policies or
troops or so forth.
Today,
I just want you to feel and understand how empowered you are to find a problem
and solve a problem.
That's what gives me hope that entrepreneurs by definition are individuals who
find problems and solve problems.
And there are more and more entrepreneurs with more and more data.
We more and more computational power with more and more access to capital
solving more and more problems.
So I wouldn't give you that perspective for a moment.
Another area,
uh,
I'm excited about.
I serve as founder and executive chairman of the x prize foundation.
Jack is,
uh,
for a while now,
since the earliest days,
one of my trustees.
And so we,
we focused on,
uh,
what are the world's biggest problems and they're not being solved.
And how do we set a very clear objective and say,
I don't care.
You know who you are,
where you went to school,
what you've ever done.
If you solve this problem and hit these metrics,
you win.
And to the very first x prize was from my,
you know,
nine year old childhood passion of space for I gave up on NASA being the way I
was gonna go to space.
I did the math and your chance are right.
Mark went in a thousand of being a NASA astronaut,
I had a better chance of becoming an NBA all star at five five.
And I did a NASA astronaut.
And so,
uh,
when I read that Lindbergh in 1927 cross the Atlantic to win a $25,000 prize and
looked at the numbers,
nine team spent 400,000 trying to win this $25,000 prize.
And Raymond Orteig spent nothing on the losers,
only paid the winner,
and Lindbergh was the most unlikely guide to do it.
So I said,
okay,
I'm gonna create a prize for space.
Flight is going to be a $10 million prize.
10 million was enough money to inspire the entrepreneurs,
but not the Airbus,
the Boeing.
The Lockheed,
I don't want the large players just buying the prize.
I wanted true innovation.
Uh,
that $10 million prize inspired 26 teams around the world who spent $100
million.
They're all optimists and Burt Rutan back by Paul Allen,
who we just lost a funded that prize development and one it was spacial plan.
Richard Branson came in,
bought the rights to create virgin galactic.
Richard is publicly announced,
he expects a flight to space approximately this month.
So fingers crossed,
we'll see something three weeks left in the month or there abouts.
And then we on the heels of that [inaudible] an amazing board and very proud
that we've had as board members and benefactors,
Larry and Sergei and Eric and,
and in a multitude of,
of Googlers in the earliest days.
Uh,
and folks like Elon Musk and Jim Cameron and um,
Ratan Tata.
And so we've launched a bunch of prize.
Let me give you a few that are active right now just for fun.
Uh,
Elon funded a global learning x prize and we asked teams,
can you build a piece of android software that could take a child in the middle
of no place from illiteracy to reading,
writing,
and numeracy,
and under 18 months.
And so Sundar very kindly gave us 5,000 android tablets,
uh,
with the World Food Program.
We went into Tanzania where we are right now.
We interviewed hundreds of villages and we found 2,500 kids who knew,
know Swahili,
no English,
and put the tablets in their hands.
We had 800 teams enter the competition,
141 ish delivered software.
We narrowed it to five finalists.
Those five finalists are in 500 tablets each in the villages.
Right now.
We're measuring the impact on the child,
the family and the village.
And then we're going to open source the winning software.
Uh,
the goal would be that this becomes part of,
you know,
android kernal for example,
and the notion that every time an android devices built,
it's a teacher.
All right,
we're,
we're building a billion teachers a year.
Uh,
we had to go into those villages and set up power there.
So that's one x prize we're doing.
Uh,
one that we just awarded is called the water abundance x prize.
You know,
half the disease burden on planet earth is due to unclean drinking water.
And so we asked the,
the team,
could you pull water out of the atmosphere there?
Quadrillions of liters of water in the atmosphere when it,
you know,
when it condenses on particles,
we call it rain.
Um,
and could you pull the APP but water out of the atmosphere,
2000 liters for under 2 cents per leader from all renewable energy.
And,
uh,
we just awarded the winner of that competition,
about a month ago.
Uh,
I just came back from Greece and a,
we have a,
an x prize going on right now on,
um,
on mapping the ocean floor.
We've mapped less than 5%.
The ocean floor,
uh,
the physics of salt water.
It makes it very difficult.
And so we said to win this prize at $7 million put up by shell and by Noah,
uh,
you've got to build an autonomous vehicle that can launch from land,
go out some,
some distance,
tens of kilometers into the ocean,
then go down 4,000 meters and map 250 square kilometers in 24 hours on its own
return and provide the data,
right?
So fully autonomous,
large scale mapping.
Uh,
we're down to five finalists that are in,
in Greece right now off the coast of the mainland.
And uh,
I met two of the five teams.
One team is a group of 13 academics and Grad students from Germany of their team
is two people at a Switzerland on the team is out of Japan.
And it's amazing what they're doing.
It's transforming,
uh,
what's possible in ocean.
One of my favorite x prize is going on right now is called the Avatar x prize.
And we asked teams to build a robotic avatar.
So a robot.
So imagine I'm not here,
I'm back in Santa Monica where I live.
And at home,
I've got on a pair of VR goggles and a haptic suit.
And as I'm moving around the robots moving around as I'm looking at you,
the robot's looking at you.
So it's basically a remote,
uh,
Avatar,
a telepresence to allow you to go and,
um,
and solve a problem,
do a medical diagnostic,
go into a disaster zone and so forth.
So we have over 400 teams entering that competition.
So a lot of x prize is going on.
We can dive into more when,
when Jack and I talk or you have your questions.
Now the area I'm passionate about is human longevity.
Uh,
I'm clear we're going to be able to add 10,
20,
potentially 30 healthy years and everyone's life,
right?
Google.
It's got a massive investment in Calico,
uh,
besides Calico.
There's a multitude of different companies going on right now,
company down in San Diego,
Samu Med that's using,
that's manipulating a wind pathways,
which is a communication pathway that's a $13 billion private company because
the results are extraordinary.
They're in phase two clinical trials on a multitude of different,
um,
anticancer hair growth,
anti wrinkles,
osteogenesis.
I mean,
it's incredible what they're doing.
Uh,
you see companies like unity bio-sciences,
which are working on synthetic medicines to kill senile cells,
cells that have grown to the Hayflick limit and have stopped,
uh,
replicating.
And then it becoming inflammatory agents.
If you can kill those cells and make room for new cells to generate from
endogenous stem cells,
the organism regenerates and,
uh,
you get an extended lifespan.
Uh,
another,
uh,
I have two companies in the longevity business.
Um,
one is in the stem cell business called cellularity.
Uh,
we have the world's largest bank of placentas.
Turns out you can think of the placenta as the three d printer that
manufacturers the baby,
and that placenta is the richest source of stem cells.
And so those stem cells delivered back to an aging organism can extend life 30
plus percent.
As we age our stem cells in our bodies and all the compartments fall off very
rapidly over time.
And so one of the reasons for aging is we lose the ability to regenerate
ourselves,
to repair ourselves or the stem cells in our body.
They will drop a hundred to a thousand x in population,
but they undergo epigenetic changes,
mutations and so forth,
and they're not capable as they were before.
So stem cell replenishment is another area,
a one fun one,
uh,
that uh,
that I cofounded called human longevity.
We're down in San Diego,
we'll be opening around the country.
Uh,
and what human longevity does is you come in for three hours,
we sequence your genome,
all 3.2 billion letters.
We do a 30 x sequencing on you.
We sequence your microbiome.
We look at the,
your metabolome basically the top 100 plus uh,
proteins in your and chemicals and you're a small molecules in your bloodstream.
We do a full body MRI,
head to toe,
a brain MRI,
brain vasculature,
coronary CT,
lung CT,
and then we feed about 150 gigabytes of data into our system to determine two
things.
Number one,
is there anything going on inside your body right now that you should know
about?
And number two,
based upon your genetics,
what are you likely to die from and how do you find it before?
So the numbers are pretty telling.
The price point initially for uh,
for Hli,
the what's called the health nucleus,
the facility was 25,000 bucks.
So it's not cheap.
All the people who came were very,
uh,
well to do patients,
so to speak.
Uh,
the price has dropped down to 5,000 and 3000 for subsequent visits,
but still,
uh,
then we in 2%,
right?
So we're in a room of our roughly 102 of you have a brain or Aortic aneurysm you
don't know about,
which is kind of shocking.
2% and this is for population to older than you are here for 50 and older,
have a,
uh,
have a high grade cancer tumor,
a 3.4% have a significant cardiac condition,
atrial fibrillation or,
or bundle branch block or so like,
and we find 14% of the people who've come through have significant findings and
you take action on immediately.
So the fact of the matter is we're all optimists.
We think everything's fine in our body.
And then until you go to the hospital,
at which point you're like,
oh shit,
you know,
I didn't know that.
And,
but I'm a pilot.
I fly a couple of planes before I take off,
make sure everything's in the green.
But for most of us,
we don't know that.
Eventually we'll all have wearables.
We were talking about,
I have my aura ring here rightly about that 1415 different sensors that measure
my pulse wave form,
my temperature,
my acceleration,
and give me sleep data.
Um,
I've got my Apple Watch,
I've got a small little frid chip implanted over here.
It's got my business card on it.
I'm completely useless,
but eventually it will be something useful.
But we'll all have this data uploaded to give us minute by minute how we're
doing.
And the goal people say,
I don't want to know if,
and he's wrong with me.
Bullshit.
Of course you want to know and you want to solve it right then at the very
beginning when it's most solvable,
right?
So it's going from sick here,
which is what it is right now.
We take care of you after your sick to healthcare?
Do you find anything at stage zero?
So I'll,
I'll close singularity university.
Ray and I,
10 years ago,
uh,
what month are we in?
Like 10 years ago,
two months ago,
we announced x.
Now in singularity university,
uh,
I was reading Ray's book,
the singularity is near,
and I said,
there's no place in the world you can go and not Harvard and Mit,
not Stanford,
not superior or whatever it might be that you can go and actually get an
overview of all the exponential technologies and understand what they're able to
do in convergence.
So we created a graduate program.
It's now called the global startup program.
Our goal is a thousand startups a year.
And then we started,
uh,
executive programs or six day programs were executives come in and we'd give
them an overview of what's going on in all the technologies and how they're
converging.
And it's really about,
you know,
awareness and education,
but it's,
it's,
we're growing,
you know,
a good clip of 30 to 50% year on year.
So I'll pause there and,
uh,
bring in
maestro
a great opening talk.
Thank you.
Let's start with kind of activity.
Uh,
1969,
our Punnett,
it's taken 50 years since then to get 3 billion,
just about 40% of the world connected.
4 billion people not yet connected to the Internet to everything that in this
room,
uh,
we work on,
we build on,
we engage in and other companies up and down silicon valley and around the
world.
Um,
talk to us about a world of the numbers indicate not from us,
but from third party sources that well,
it took 50 years to get to 3 billion.
We might get the next 3 billion.
That is the doubling of the number of people internet in about within six,
maybe seven years.
Yeah,
very,
very soon.
Paint us a picture of that world,
the world where suddenly,
uh,
you know,
huge swaths of countries,
uh,
and others that are not online today suddenly become part of not just the
information flow,
but also the global economy,
buying,
selling,
putting stuff into markets.
Talk to us about that kind of world
question.
Uh,
so first of all,
layers of conductivity that are coming online,
right?
And five g is probably one of the,
the biggest,
uh,
incredible explosions coming online.
Uh,
we'll see test deployments in 2019 and really full deployments in 2020 and
onward.
And you know,
10 gigabit connection speeds means you're downloading a movie in a fraction of a
second.
You take your new LG TV set and put it on the wall,
you plug in the power and it's got,
you know,
500 channels all of a sudden.
So five g is gonna is gonna spread like Kudzu on the planet.
Uh,
on top of that,
obviously loon is now been spun out as its own company.
You've got one point $2 billion of money from Masa son at Softbank backing one
web.
Then you've got Elon who is gotten if FCC permission for 11,000 satellites,
you know,
a set,
a 4,000 satellite layer and a 7,000 satellite layer called cold space link,
right?
It's startling,
which is incredible.
And then you've got a terabit Boeing satellites in a meal orbit.
So we're basically covering the entire planet with bandwidth.
And then on top of that,
we're going all have all of these micro cells on non licensed bands.
I think eventually we're all going to be dribbling bits all the time.
And our AI is going to be negotiating prices on different mechanisms.
So that sounds like a great future.
Dribbling this,
dribbling,
dribbling bits.
We're all going to be dribbling bits,
you know,
I think we're all going to have our own personal version of Jarvis eventually,
right?
Google now and echo and Siri are all,
all versions of that,
which are,
which you give permission to have access to everything.
Your email,
your conversation to your,
your microbiome,
your cure bloodstream.
And it's transacting constantly.
But so 8 billion people potentially connected in the next six years,
um,
as the price comes down.
Now the question is,
can they afford these devices?
I,
and so can the poorest people in the world afford those devices?
So I've seen years ago,
uh,
engineering drawings for a $20 cell phone or $20 tablet,
there is a price point at which the price of the device gets so cheap that
Google is going to give them away,
right?
And Amazon's going to give them away to get the traffic to get the data to get
the transactions.
So I think we are heading very quickly towards a world of 8 billion people that
are digitally connected.
And if you do the math right,
I mean,
and I,
I,
I'm screaming this from the rooftops and no one's talking about this,
which drives me nuts because 4 billion new people connected.
And if they're just transacting on the average $10 a day,
that's tens of trillions of dollars flowing into the global economy that no
one's talking about.
And,
and the market,
all of these 4 billion new digital,
you know,
digital newbies are all going to want insurance and banking and education and
healthcare.
They're also going to be creating content,
right?
They're gonna be creating content.
Now there's a certain number of dominant players creating a lot of the content.
And also the of course is distributed content and crowd source content,
but 4 billion people are not yet part of that conversation.
And,
and what's going to happen is they'll generate content,
they'll generate revenue,
but they're also going to demand these services at diminimous,
you know,
freemium prices and it,
it,
and I had talked to insurance companies and banks and I say,
listen,
this is coming.
I said,
but that's not my marketplace.
So it's fine.
It's not your marketplace today,
but some entrepreneur within 50 kilometers of ground zero here is working on
delivering value to those individuals when the new business model and then when
it starts working and they'll bring it back to New York and Chicago and eat your
lunch,
they're great.
Let's switch gears because we have a limited time.
Let's go open with genomics.
The first genome sequence,
Craig Venter's,
you know it was about 3 billion,
went down to 100 million,
hit a thousand now about 500 and as you mentioned,
probably were on the way to $100 would have been even less.
And of course the analysis with that is as important as the sequence itself.
And that's starting to ramp up the bioinformatics around it.
Estimates are there right now in total putting aside smaller genomic tests,
but in terms of whole genome sequencing,
there may be are a few hundred thousand maximum a million people who may be at a
seven plus billion people.
When do we get to a critical mass that helps us understand the significance of
billions of those base pairs that we don't understand yet the sequence
significance of,
in other words,
we have a lot of good sense about the usual 500 that are cancer drivers that are
Onco genes.
We don't have a good sense of literally billions plus of some of those,
uh,
you know,
base pairs in sequence.
Tell us about the critical mass.
We need to start on the sand,
the sample size that we need to.
So,
so we're getting amazing results with tens of thousands right now at Hli.
I can't,
I can't state this stuff until it's published,
but traditionally we talk about the exome,
the part of the genome that codes for proteins.
And the s two has been euphemistically called junk DNA,
but it's not junk DNA.
None of it's junk DNA.
It's all in some way structural or coding or control segments.
And it's interesting that as you look at enough large enough population,
you start to say,
listen,
these segments of the DNA are protected.
Any mutation here is lethal to the person,
right?
So we start to discover by elimination and by subtraction,
fascinating parts of the genome that are worth looking at.
And the other thing I might just say is it's the correlation.
What was really exciting as the correlation between genome and then rich
phenotypic data,
right?
When we've got your genome and then we have full body MRI and coronary and heart
CT and metabolome and so forth.
Then you start to really correlate,
Aha,
that's what this does,
right?
And I was going to get to methylation of right now genome sequence coming down.
But the ability to get to epigenetics in terms of methyl groups,
things like that,
talk to us about all the other rich information that's necessary.
It really draw those conclusions.
So I think one of the things that is true is this next decade is going to be
just discovery after discovery and I think AI is going to play the most is is
the only way we're going to make sense of all of it.
The amount of data that's coming out.
And I remember when I was in medical school,
what got me on this path of one of my massively transformative purposes is
making a hundred years old and you're 60 how do we have at a hundred the
cognition,
the aesthetics and mobility that we had at 60 I remember watching a TV show on
long live sea life that some
whales could live hundreds years.
Sharks could live four or 500 years,
turtles could six,
700 years.
And I was like,
if they can,
why can't we?
Right?
And it's either a software problem or a hardware problem,
but we need to swim more apt to be in a water cooler.
Body temperature's down.
But,
but I really think we're going to start to unravel that and understand it.
And let's jump to another area of healthcare,
which is our brains.
You mentioned that we're going to live longer and it's already happening in a
number of countries,
but that also now is revealing greater populations with Alzheimer's,
Parkinson's,
neurological diseases.
Um,
we have,
we've had a good handle so far on cardiac diseases.
Morbidity from chronic has actually come down.
Diabetes is on the rise,
but there's some hopes there,
but talks about the neurological diseases.
Yeah,
so,
so
we have cardiac conditions in our fifties and sixties we have cancers in our
sixties and seventies and we hid neurological disease in our seventies and 80s
and the fact that matter is just for context.
I like that until you prevent it,
right.
Life is short and to the extend it and and so forth.
But the human body was never intended to live past age 30 I mean,
just to put it on the table here,
right?
You would go into puberty at age 13 you'd have a baby and then by the time we
were 26 your baby's having a baby.
And back then a hundred thousand years ago before whole foods and Mcdonald's was
around right?
When food was scarce,
the last thing you wanted to do for the selfish gene was to take the money out
of your grandchildren's mouths and now compete with them.
So you would do the best thing you could give your bits back in the environment.
But of course that's changed now and we're beginning to extend life.
And as we extend life,
we run into new problems.
Um,
there is,
uh,
amazing drugs in phase two clinical trials right now.
Uh,
we're seeing impact from synthetic medicines.
We're seeing impacts from wind pathway manipulations on cancers and uh,
and Alzheimer's.
Um,
uh,
I think one of the areas that is super exciting as well as the whole field of
brain computer interface,
right?
My last count,
there's probably $1 billion a year going into interfacing your neocortex with
the cloud,
uh,
in buildings not far from here.
And so at the end of the day,
we're going to learn a lot about how the brain works and the root causes of
these diseases as we have over and over again.
But a lot of it's going to come.
Our ability to sense and gathered data and analyze the data is,
you know,
billions trillions of times,
better than ever.
Now let's turn to one of your first passion space.
Oh sure.
Let's talk about really space travel that's um,
we hear from Branson that it may be imminent,
uh,
Virgin Galactic maybe launching imminently with paying customers and has been a
long line of thousands of people putting their bets,
uh,
in terms of their down payments on getting a seat on that ride.
Um,
which is,
it's great to see that virgin galactic ticket holder is here in the audience.
So the curiosity.
Okay.
Lots of customers potential.
Exactly.
I'll take gut checks later.
Um,
but,
but talk to us about what you see as the odds that we're going to be a multi
planet species within,
say,
10 years,
20 years,
50 years.
Sure.
We obviously have the potential that technology,
I don't think that there's doubt that we can actually get to another planet now,
but,
but talks about the will and the mobilization to make that happen.
Yeah.
So,
probably the single most important driver that's making that happen is the
individual passionate actor in this case,
in the form of Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos and Richard Branson and just passed up
Paul Allen.
And it's interesting,
right?
A lot of these individuals grew up in the case of Jeff Webb known for 35 years
since the early days of said,
cause I was a founder of sets and said Jeff around the Princeton chapter,
I remember meeting Jeff after he started Amazon.
What are you doing with this Amazon thing?
And he goes,
well,
I'm gonna make a lot of money there and spend it on space.
No Shit,
really any lawns committed,
said I will spend all his money on opening up space.
That is his,
both of them are that committed.
And I think a lot of it was those who were born during the Apollo and shuttle
era got enamored with this vision right from star wars and star trek and all of
those things.
And then NASA never implemented it.
Never.
It never paid off on the deal.
And so now you've got individual saying,
we'll do it.
Um,
I,
I've known Ilan since he sold paypal and just watched what he did with,
with uh,
with space x,
with the Falcon one and one Ian Falcon nine and heavy.
And I would never bet against him.
He is dead set on making that happen.
And I think he will,
uh,
you know,
he set a target at landing in 2024 on the Martian surface a cake.
Listen,
I'll give him an extra four years.
Um,
but could he get there by 2028 I would bet on him over any government hands
down.
Uh,
and then Jeff is sort of the,
uh,
the term,
the tortoise in the race,
right?
He's committed $1 billion a year and he's just,
that is his end,
his end game.
And so I think we're going to do it.
I think it's going to be a function of,
um,
you know,
I don't think governments can take the risks anymore that were inherent in the
early Apollo program days.
It's way to,
failure is not an option for them and therefore risk is no option either.
But individuals can say,
I'm going to do this.
I mean,
you know,
there is a Tesla on a earth asteroid return.
That's insane.
I mean,
just like game over
point.
Yeah.
Um,
you mentioned a number of great entrepreneurs and we can see how they're
changing the world.
So let's talk about entrepreneurship now.
Here in Silicon Valley,
we know the power of entrepreneurship.
We see it,
we feel it.
These other key entrepreneurial centers around the world,
but it's not spread evenly enough yet.
It's not as inclusive as it needs to be and could be.
And not only is that the case,
we're missing out on the talents of many of those people from diverse
backgrounds that could be part of the entrepreneurial journey and journey.
Um,
what are your thoughts around how to change that game?
So first of all,
we're dematerializing democratizing demonetizing all the tools for
entrepreneurship,
right?
So it used to be that to be an entrepreneur,
you need it to have computational power.
You need to have an ethernet cable or a modem plug or whatever.
And you needed to have,
now obviously it would Google cloud and AWS,
you have all the computational power you want by the number is by 2023,
I believe there'll be $300 billion available in crowdfunding,
which means anyone around the world with a good idea can launch a crowdfunding
campaign to get the capital.
So capital becomes less of a restriction.
Um,
obviously Google makes the world's information available.
So what used to be scarce resources,
um,
I mean bandwidth.
I remember back in 2001 night I stealth company called blastoff,
my number one expense was Akamai on bandwidth to send video to people.
It was like ridiculous.
And now it's nothing.
So we're literally everything you need to be to,
uh,
to create an entrepreneurial startup is becoming available globally at lower
lower costs.
Uh,
and so it's now the number one scarce resource that I seen entrepreneurship
around the world is mindset.
So I was just in Greece at an Su Athens summit,
a meeting there with heads of the country and the entrepreneurs,
and they were saying,
what do we need to do to become more innovative?
It's a country of 10 million people.
It's like one Google size success story dwarfs the budget of the country.
So it's like you need to create a mindset of entrepreneurship.
You have to have the,
you know,
some venture capital would be great,
but failure needs to be an option to a lot of central and South American
countries.
If you fail,
it's a black mark for life right here.
We call it success at x.
You know,
you celebrate a failure every week when somebody gives up their,
their,
their company and say,
we're going to spend our money and our time someplace else better.
That's amazing.
So it's teaching that,
that mindset of failure.
I had this conversation with rights and talk to one of our fellow trustees
who,
who in India,
it's really hard.
If you fail,
you're screwed.
And so you don't take big steps.
And so he wanted to sort of dismiss that ethos.
And so he was like,
we're going to celebrate failure.
We're going to celebrate a great idea that was worth trying,
that failed and give this person their next shot.
So speaking of that mindset breakthrough,
and then we'll turn to one or two questions.
So it is,
if people want to line up the tea to Mike,
if people have questions,
um,
you know,
you've,
you've now STM is now trained,
I don't know,
thousands of people.
It must be now and exponential thinking and through x prize and others,
you've also touched a lot of people and change a lot of people's mindset about
what is possible.
Um,
you know,
when you go back to the news reports on polio back in the early part of last
century,
it's written in such a way that people never thought it could be overcome.
Today when people speak about cancer,
yes,
incremental progress.
But most people,
when you ask them,
they don't believe that in their lifetime,
we're going to see the management and containment of cancers.
So identify for us three or four things that you think we should apply
exponential breakthrough thinking and we're not doing today.
We're going to look back 30 40 years from now and say we were people like polio,
you know,
looking at polio in the same way that we should have had a different mindset.
The Sherman.
So let me talk about where the places
x prizes as a as a perfect example,
right?
So first of all,
we are in final steps for what I hope will be $100 million cancer x prize for
going beyond liquid biopsy,
but very early detection.
Something like a blood test or something like a pap smear or something that is
tens of dollars.
Very easy to do type of detection.
We're also working on a an Alzheimer's x prize,
same order of magnitude.
One of my favorite prizes that I want to do right now is a fire detection and
extinction x prize.
The idea that we don't know when a fire starts is ridiculous,
right?
So this is a simple x prize for me.
A team has given 500 square kilometers of forest land and you have to detect a
fire above a certain lumen level.
Let's say five campfires worth the Ryan and you have to put it out within 10
minutes.
And I don't care how you do it with drones,
with water balloons,
whether the case might be,
I think if that technology exists,
you insurance makes it possible and deploys it across all forest lands.
We don't have devastating forest fires again.
Right?
So I'd love to do,
uh,
working on a,
earthquake prediction x prize.
I think it's a massive data play.
There's no way in the world that a magnitude six earthquake doesn't leave a
digital trail before it unleashes 30 Hiroshima bombs of energy working on a,
a hurricane trajectory prediction x prize.
So it turns out that,
uh,
that,
you know,
all those wide area projections of our hurricane caused devastation.
And if you can measure wind velocity at 10 meters above the center of the eye of
a hurricane,
that's the missing data.
So is there a drone or a technology for doing that accurately?
There's energy x prize.
We're working on a feeding the next billion x prize for a massive protein food
production.
The way that we grow our protein today.
This is a planet for cows if you didn't know,
right.
One third of our non ice landmass is used in theater,
is used for,
uh,
is used for livestock production and that's crazy with CO2,
water,
energy and so forth.
So,
uh,
we've been working with a lot of the companies that are in the beginning of
cultured meat to create a large scale cultured meat x prize for,
uh,
for,
meat and plant stem cell meat and plant based derivative that tastes better than
what you buy.
And I guess finally,
I know you've been thinking about housing for awhile in terms of the ability to
medicine from an x prize,
but in general,
can we provide housing,
you know,
for folks.
So with that,
we have time for two questions and we have two questions.
Most of these x prizes have to do with science and technology
or when they evolved humans,
they treat humans as individual units.
How are you doing x prize that involves connections between humans?
This in this,
the social space?
What would they be?
Groups of people or a behavioral prizes?
Yes.
Yeah.
To be clear.
X prizes that have been successful so far have been for widgets,
devices,
transportation modes and things like that where people can go and have a very
clear measurable objective and can rapidly iterate.
We've talked about doing competitions between regions,
like cities or companies and so forth.
One my favorite x prize ideas,
and actually the very first person I ever mentioned this was Larry Page would be
a,
it's a two part prize.
One would be a happiness x.
It's called a happiness x prize.
Could you build a device that could physiologically measure your state of
happiness?
Like if I asked you right now,
are you happy I'm a seven right?
And the time you don't be a 10 or two,
whatever it is.
But if you could actually accurately measure,
they even create,
you could create a policy change at Google and then measure of did it make
people happier or not.
So I think the ability to measure first and then create state changes afterwards
would be nice.
My approach to that,
but we haven't done it successful yet.
We keep on banging our heads against it and continue to.
But thank you for that.
You talked a lot about accelerating technologies in the near term or the term
future.
And my question had to do with,
uh,
do you think there's any risk of these accelerating technologies being misused
by bad actors in the shorter near term?
I'm thinking of things like China's social credit system,
which just seems kind of like,
I dunno a nightmare to me,
but like what are your thoughts on that?
Yeah,
so the answer is of course.
Um,
and I would just say listen to social credit system.
First of all,
anybody who went through school and got an a,
a,
B or a c or higher,
you know,
review.
We,
we've had that all through our lives.
It's the negative externalities that are the issue with that.
But being able to tell a person how there's good parts of a social credit
system,
if it's for the upside,
not for the downside.
Sure.
Um,
just to be clear,
not to defend what they're doing there,
to be very clear.
Uh,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I'm clear that even though the world is getting better by almost every measure,
uh,
you know,
the cost of food,
energy,
water,
health care,
all these things are plummeting.
As life is going up.
As you know,
childhood mortality rates have plummeted from 45% of people have kids,
diamond or h five to now 4%.
All of these metrics are getting better and better
and I think they'll continue to,
we're still gonna have terrorism,
we're still going to have warfare,
will still have a whole bunch of things.
The thing that gives me the greatest hope for,
uh,
for not being decimated is that it's harder and harder to do anything in secret.
It's,
it's the flip side of loss of privacy that there are cameras all the time
everywhere,
right?
A single autonomous car with a lidar at generating 750 megabytes of data as it's
going down the road to everything's being imaged.
Whatever augmented reality goggles we're all going to be wearing are going to
have,
you know,
a millimeter cameras looking out,
1.6 million drones flying over the sky as the United States.
So everything is going to be visualized and so your ability to do something in
secret becomes harder and harder.
And that lets me sleep a little bit better at night.
But ultimately when I do my calculus,
the question is,
are there more good people in the world using these technologies or bad?
Sure.
We don't leave that to you.
All right,
thank you.
Thank you.
So final word of advice to those in this room on livestream and good wash the
sun and Youtube around the world.
You're at a company like Google,
you're another company and you're managing five 10 20 people,
maybe a hundred people.
What is your advice to somebody as they're growing their career as they're
building products to kind of tap into the kind of exponential focus that you
have that you kind of live every day,
but in the practical day to day sets,
what is your advice to folks?
So,
first of all,
don't do anything you don't absolutely love doing.
I don't have to
say it more clearly than that.
I did do anything big and bold in the world and make a difference on the planet
is hard.
It's extraordinarily hard.
And if you don't love doing what you're doing,
you're going to give up before you get there.
Right?
So any of my successes are,
you know,
overnight successes after 11 years of hard work.
And I just did not.
I refuse to give up and sometimes there's an important point to give up.
Uh,
but I didn't cause you know,
for x prize like is my zero g company,
which anybody here flown in zero g mark has not yet.
Um,
you know,
it took 11 years to get FAA permission to do this with a seven 27.
I had a chance to fly Stephen Hawking.
He knows you're a GE was amazing.
Um,
but I just refuse to give up.
I mean,
I was like battling the FAA and I was thinking,
you're going to die or retire before I give up with my attitude.
And sometimes it because only because I cared about it that much.
Uh,
the other part is,
and this is what are the ethos of Google,
that the world's biggest problems are the world's biggest business
opportunities,
right?
I mean,
I tell people,
probably the company that's made the biggest positive impact on the planet is
Google,
right?
In terms of,
and you don't have to be a nonprofit to create an critically better world,
um,
and then,
you know,
going to become a billionaire,
help a billion people.
So it's those kinds of mindsets.
I think that our convergent with the power that you have,
I never astrum underestimate what you can do.
Each of you are extraordinarily powerful to solve problems.
So you'd have to have that,
that committed,
passionate human mind.
Great.
Peter,
thank you.
Thank you very much.